- I watch the Oscars
because it lets me see
the human beings behind these
fantastical experiences.
- It celebrates the inner child
and the dreams of so many.
- Since I was about
seven or eight years old,
I started going to the movies with my dad.
- Growing up, as a kid, it
was always a dream of mine.
- I grew up with the Oscars.
I always dreamed about
sort of being part of
this creative community.
- Remember that you are part of a legacy,
that you're part of a world of filmmakers.
- It's celebrating my community.
- It's just a very communal
experience, I guess,
with the rest of the world.
- I'm in awe of all these
extraordinary people,
whether it's in front of the
camera or behind the camera.
- I like seeing the joys of
people's names being called.
- Alfonso Cuarón
(audience applauds)
- Rami Malek
- Lupita Nyong'o
- I love to see the best
day of someone's life,
and that's sometimes what you see.
- Understanding that they are just people,
glamorous and ethereal as they are,
but they are just other people like me
is hugely empowering and encouraging.
- It's a bit like that
movie Cinema Paradiso,
about nostalgia.
- Italy for Cinema Paradiso!
(audience applauds)
- Going to the movies
and what it represents,
family or friends and
bringing people together,
and then of course, my experience
working in this industry.
- Kind of like a opening the back door
and getting to look inside
and see what really goes on.
- Making something out of nothing.
It's magic.
- And I think that gives hope
to millions of potential
filmmakers around the world.
- It's wonderful to share those dreams.